voilà c'est fini c'est fini
des chouettes un drôle web à chialer
bailly sociale c'est plus fort que moi
je me fais à chaque fois la sensiblerie
on est des hommes fois bref
et voilà qu les plus chéris nos rouge va
tomber sur les modestes marionnettes que
nous sommes on va atteindre une à une
toutes ces lumières sont l'école comme
des papillons nous étions plus aux
brûlés nous allons remonter dans notre
petite loge insalubre et on va faire les
comptes sur la recette mais on n'a pas
réussi à obtenir sur la brute
ils n'ont même les taxes les droits
d'auteur et on a été portés au bordeaux
on les fait de publicité les pompiers de
service
je sais plus quoi encore c'est
dégueulasse est là
c'est toujours c'est ça qui compte le
public
hall qui soit là ya que ça qui compte
voilà wes quitter mes copains pleine
coupe à la 13e place à bureaux fermés
c'est bien ensemble
oui alors qu est ce qu on a rigolé on a
du mérite parce que vraiment la vie ces
paniers c'est dégueulasse telle société
de merde à fric le fric le fric vous
nous disiez midi m
mais tellement de bien de temps en temps
que faire son autocritique je verrai ça
il ya des soirs mais ce soir justement
pas ce soir soit vous comme ça justement
les affamés certains corps dans certains
endroits
si on mettait un panneau entrée
interdite aujourd'hui ça se bousculait
pas la caisse mais pas
oh
on jouera tous crever tout ce qui passe
à gauche entre la bombe les accidents de
la route même maladie la pollution du
fleuve pourrait on va pour et c'est dans
tous les journaux
aux dernières nouvelles c'est les rares
voix sur vous fait il pas évident non
plus normaux on n'a aucune chance de
s'en tirer
à bientôt